[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be talking about Jaden and the
hidden source of his immense almost
unfathomable power so far in Dragon Ball
super we have all seen that Jian is
strong insanely strong we also know that
he has a strong sense of justice and
that he has a wish that he desperately
wants granted but other than that we
don't know very much about Darren's
background and we don't know how he came
to be as strong as he is I have been
thinking about this question ever since
Jaden was first introduced what is the
secret of his power and so in this video
I will share my theory about what makes
Jaron so strong and what makes him so
special
among all the mortals I believe that
Jian has one critical advantage and this
advantage is one of the biggest factors
that make him such a powerful and
effective fighter I also believe that
the story of Dragon Ball super and the
universe survival arc in particular has
been set up in such a way that ultra
instinct and specifically Goku's ultra
instinct omen form will prove crucial
for ultimately defeating Jaden and this
will be directly related to the secret
source of Giants power I will go through
all the clues that we have been given
throughout the universe survival saga
about jaren's unique power and I will
present my case for what I think
Kieran's hidden advantage is and why I
believe that ultra instinct will prove
to be the key to defeating Jaden as
always feel free to let me know in the
comments if you have theories of your
own for why jiren is so strong I love to
get a good discussion going before we
get started I want to thank you all for
the awesome feedback and support that
you've been giving us on our Dragon Ball
super videos here at Anime uproar we've
been making Dragon Ball super content
for about five or six months but in the
past month or so we've gotten so much
support and incur
from you guys and we've decided to make
more Dragon Ball super content because
of that so thank you all for the support
for requesting more content and a lot
more is on the way if you enjoyed these
Dragon Ball super videos be sure to
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell if you want to support the channel
and get cool anime merch like your girl
calls me senpai and keep calm and ultra
instinct you can check out our merch
store link in the description and we are
now posting daily on Twitter at
Instagram so be sure to follow us at
anime up roar now do you remember the
quick scene in episode 109 where Belle
mod communicates telepathically with GM
and tells him to stop saving his
strength because it is time to crush
Goku when I first saw this scene I
thought it was very cool Belle mod has
the perfect creepy clown vibe and
clearly both he and Kirin have a strong
relationship of mutual respect when
everything around them seems to turn
black as they communicate telepathically
it reminded me of the show stranger
things and specifically the character xi
or l when she is using her psychic
ability to listen in on people who are
far away this short scene with jiren and
belmont stuck with me for weeks until it
eventually inspired the idea for this
video now in that scene we see Belmonte
communicating with jarran telepathically
telepathic powers are nothing new to
Dragon Ball super or the Dragon Ball
franchise as a whole
telepathy is used to communicate quite
often and it has been used throughout
the Dragon Ball franchise by everyone
from Master Roshi and Tian to Koren
piccolo King Kai and even Vegeta and
Goku telepathy essentially means
transmitting information from one person
to another mentally rather than through
physical communication and as I said it
is pretty common in Dragon Ball but now
let's look at some important clues about
Jeter hits time-skip
did not work on Jaron as Jaron was able
to anticipate and counter hit over and
over again and Jaron didn't even
need any time to get adjusted to the
time-skip technique like Goku did when
he first fought hit in the scene where
hit uses his ultimate technique the cage
of time on Jairam after struggling for
only a brief moment cheerin is able to
break the cage of time with just a glare
we clearly see something flash in his
eyes and he is then able to overcome the
cage of time to the point that vados
comments that dierence power transcends
time itself but what can this power be
if it transcends time itself what does
it all mean
Kieran's glare is the key if you think
back to the first fight between Gian and
Goku cheerin is able to push the spirit
bomb back at Goku with just a focused
glare and during the battle with hit we
see turns eyes flash before he is able
to stop hits attack with again just a
glare then just seconds later we see
Gerrans eyes flash a really freaky red
color and it looks like he is attacking
hit without even moving hit receives
dozens of blows in rapid succession
while jiren appears to just stay in the
same spot as if he isn't even moving now
of course we've seen incredibly fast
characters in Dragon Ball before so
maybe jiren is just so fast that he can
hit an opponent dozens of times and even
push the opponent back even though it
looks like he is standing still however
there is another possibility here aside
from being able to telepathically listen
in on others who are far away 11 the
character with psychic powers in
stranger things has another type of
power while telepathy simply means
communicating with others through mental
rather than physical communication
telekinesis is the psychic ability to
manipulate the physical space around you
just by willing it with your mind
that means that you can actually move
objects or even attack others with just
your mind in stranger things 11 the care
with psychic powers can use telekinesis
to accomplish incredible feats of
strength such as lift an entire van with
just her mind so what if the key to
gerrans power is some form of incredibly
potent telekinesis what if the reason he
can attack others with just his glare is
his ability to use telekinesis to attack
and if this is true and jiren has some
form of psychic power this would give
him another crucial advantage as well
what if the reason that Jilin is able to
overcome hits time-skip so easily and
anticipate hits attacks even though hit
inhabits a completely different space
while attacking is that giance
telekinetic powers allow him to read
hits intentions before he even attacks
in other words what if jiren has the
psychic ability to read his mind even if
only for a few seconds and this unique
ability allows him to anticipate hits
movements and act so quickly to counter
them after all in stranger things 11
psychic abilities also transcend
physical space they even transcend
dimensions so the concept of telekinetic
powers transcending space and time is
already out there think back to the
scene where the CACCI koch and blocks
are flying everywhere and everyone
hurries to move out of their way except
for one person
that person is Jayden who is able to
anticipate perfectly where the blocks
will land so he doesn't even move
but blocks do not have key or energy
that can be sensed so why was Jia and
the only person who was able to
perfectly anticipate the movement of
these blocks either jian is really
really good at geometry or his unique
psychic abilities allowed him to sense
and anticipate the movements of the
blocks even though they have no key
this idea that Jian uses psychic
abilities and telekinesis would also
explain why we see Jian closing his eyes
so often and even
meditating in the middle of the
tournament he closes his eyes to focus
his mind which allows him to anticipate
the intentions of his opponents and he
uses meditation as a way to focus and
strengthen his psychic powers so that he
is ready to go when he needs to fight
again don't forget that while meditating
jiren seems to be deliberately
destroying the rocks that are floating
around him one by one as if he is
focusing and honing his telekinetic
ability as if he is actually training
but in a completely different way than
the one were used to Jaron isn't
training physically he is training
mentally and now here's the kicker if it
is true that Jaden possesses psychic
abilities to read the intentions of his
opponents and anticipate their attacks
as soon as they cross the opponent's
mind this sets up the perfect conclusion
to the tournament of power
just remember what ultra instinct
actually is it is the ability to make
your body move on its own to avoid
attacks without even thinking but aside
from avoiding attacks which Goku has
more or less mastered there is also the
attack side of ultra instinct during the
battle with kefla we stels us that Goku
is still thinking while he is attacking
he has not mastered the attacking side
of ultra instinct and this is why his
attacks were still not very effective
against kefla and if Jian has the power
to read Goku's mind
Goku will never be able to defeat
cheerin until he masters the attacking
side of ultra instinct until he can
attack without even thinking as soon as
Goku accomplishes this or potentially
Vegeta accomplishes it and then fuses
with Goku or something along those lines
then gene and psychic ability will be
useless he cannot read
Goku's mind and anticipate his attack if
Goku is attacking without thinking and
this is how Goku wins this is how Goku
ultimately defeats Jaden but only after
mastering the attacking side of both
instinct there is also the possibility
as I said for Vegeta to master the
attacking side of ultra instinct wall
Goku has already mastered the defensive
side and then potentially the two of
them together or even fused as vegeto
are going to be able to defeat jiren and
even if that happens whether it's Goku
or Goku and Vegeta together or Vegeta
I think it would be a really cool way to
wrap up the entire arc including the
whole concept of ultra instinct and the
idea of learning to fight without
thinking but let me know what you guys
think does Jaron have some form of
psychic or telekinetic ability which
allows him to attack with just a glare
to overcome hits time skips so easily
and to anticipate the movements of his
opponents and also to anticipate the
movements of lifeless blocks that don't
have key or is during just ridiculously
strong physically there definitely seem
to be a lot of clues about Gian's of
mental power attacking with just a glare
from his eyes closing his eyes often as
if to focus his mind meditating in the
middle of the tournament and so on but
it is also possible that his strength is
mostly physical we can't know for sure
and that's why this is just a theory let
me know if you agree down below and if
you don't agree by all means feel free
to give me your theories about the true
source of Giants power right there in
the comments let's get a nice debate
going I'm really curious to see what
everyone thinks about your inspire and
it's true source if you enjoyed these
Dragon Ball super videos I want to see
more be sure to leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell we are now posting
daily on Twitter and Instagram including
a lot of Dragon Ball super and other
anime content so be sure to follow us at
anime up drawer as always thank you all
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]